[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on the 25th of January I'm
John Connelly The Spectators news editor
and your host this week coming up on the
show can anything stop the Donald Trump
Juggernaut Freddy gray has been in New
Hampshire this week where the Democratic
and Republican primaries have been
taking place Freddy joins me on the show
to discuss Joe Biden and Donald Trump's
presidential bids over in Scotland the
UK Co inquiry is exposing the way
Hollywood operated during the pandemic
in his cover piece editor Fraser Nelson
describes it as being less like
government and more like a mafia style
operation what does that say about the
state of Scottish Devolution Fraser
joins me on the show with journalist
Shona
Craven what's behind the dangerous rise
in ketman misuse in Britain joining me
is Max pton Mental Health doctor working
for the NHS we'll be discussing some of
the unknown health risks of ketamin and
why he's changed his mind on drug
liberalization we'll also hear from
Professor David nut a long-standing
researcher and advocate for drug
liberalization to get his take and
finally should parents be tracking their
children seems like everyone is these
days but is our safety obsessed culture
depriving young people a vital part of
growing up Mary Wakefield and deorah
heitner join me later before we get
going if you enjoy spectator TV do
subscribe subbe to our YouTube channel
just click the Subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and tap the Bell
icon so you never miss an
episode first up it was an overwhelming
Triumph for Donald Trump at the New
Hampshire primaries this week but his
runner-up Nicki Haley says she's staying
in the race short of a supreme court
block over Trump's criminal
investigations is the Republican bid a
done deal Freddy gray has been in New
Hampshire for the primaries and he joins
me
now Freddy thank you for joining us on
spectator TV from New Hampshire um where
Donald Trump has just won the Republican
primary this week I mean it he seems
like he's beaten Nicki Haley pretty
convincingly uh how much now is it
looking like he's gonna he's going to be
the presidential candidate for the rep
Republicans well I think barring uh
legal interventions or uh you know um
possible death uh Donald Trump is going
to be uh the Republican nominee I think
that's almost certain now you can say
that with certainty now um Nikki Haley
did slightly better than uh the later
polls suggested she would do there was
some polls suggesting she'd be blown out
by 20 points or so um in the in the days
before the the primary yesterday um but
in fact she came just just a mere 12
points behind Donald Trump which the
fact that that is seen as a as a as
almost a win for her uh tells you a lot
about Trump's dominance I mean he is the
Republican party now he has been for
some time uh and the real question is um
why did anybody think that they were
going to unseat him I mean if you look
at the the just the crowd attendances
between his events and any of his Rivals
um it's just very obvious that there's
still large amount of enthusiasm for
Donald Trump um and no other candidate
can come close um despite that Freddy
Nikki Haley's not conceded yet she's
she's going to carry on running I mean
why do you think that is what do you
think she's hoping for something or well
she she must be hoping for something uh
I mean she she thinks she can go down to
South Carolina and improve uh her
position I I don't see that happening at
the moment because at the moment she's
30 points behind in the polls uh South
Carolina is a much more conservative
state with a much stronger uh Trump
movement um if she if Haley couldn't win
in New Hampshire it's hard to see how
she wins anywhere really uh in the
primary cycle I mean one element of
concern for Trump or Trump's team will
be the fact that in certain counties in
New Hampshire last night uh Haley per
outperformed uh Trump in the general
election which is that's to say she got
more votes in New Hampshire primary than
Donald Trump got in the election in
certain areas of New Hampshire which
suggests that the sort of the the Haley
the sorry the Trump Animas uh is still
very very strong um and that could come
out a lot in November in fact it will
obviously come out in November if he's
the nominate what sort of Trump's sort
of view of the can the race continuing I
mean is he getting quite frustrated now
with Haley that that that it's not all
been stitched up basically um there was
a lot of talk I was at the election
night a watch party uh with the Trump
people in in nashwa last night and uh
there was a lot of sort of this is over
talk you know the race is done and you
could hear a little bit of frustration
in it at the same time I can't help
thinking at some unconscious level uh
Donald Trump quite enjoys uh the
pleasure of sort of beating Nikki Haley
over and over again um and so at some
level I think uh he doesn't mind it
carrying on but yes it makes much more
sense for his campaign to uh wrap it up
to deal with these legal challenges and
to focus on uh trying to beat Joe Biden
in
November and and on Biden um you're
writing the magazine this week about the
Democratic Primary in New Hampshire as
well which has been a bit of a sort of a
strange setup can you can you tell us a
bit about that well I have to confess
here to uh being guilty of what a few
journalists have been guilty of which is
that the the main race is so boring
predictable Donald Trump's going to win
that everybody's looking for something
interesting going on and there is
something quite interesting going on on
the Democratic side which is this uh
candidate Dean Phillips uh who's a
former congressman from
Minnesota uh who um has start he started
his campaign 10 weeks ago and there's a
rather uh complicated fight which I'll
try and sum up quickly uh between the
Democratic National Committee who run
the Democratic party and the Democratic
primaries and New Hampshire uh the
Democratic National Committee tried to
rearrange the primary schedule to make
New Hampshire not go first South
Carolina would go first uh on grounds of
sort of racial diversity because South
Carolina's more racially diverse uh New
Hampshire said no the Democratic
National Committee said uh well tough
luck the your primary won't count a lot
of Democrats are very upset about that
uh Dean Phillips uh was one of the
candidates who ignored their ban on uh
candidates running essentially and uh uh
put his name forward in 10 weeks he's
gone from nothing to 20% of the vote
here in New Hampshire uh Joe Biden still
won the Primary should be clear with
people writing in his
name um so I don't think Dean Phillips
is going to win uh the nomination
however I do think or win the nomination
on sort of conventional in a
conventional way however I do think that
Joe Biden is looking increasingly frail
uh his cognitive decline is becoming uh
increasingly apparent I think by August
by the time he's out campaigning all the
time it's going to look it's going to be
very difficult for Democrats to say
seriously uh that he's a fully
functioning president in that scenario
particularly with Trump doing so well in
the polls for the national for the
general uh you know you could quite see
a situation where they need to find
another candidate that would obviously
be camela Harris would be the Natural
Choice the vice president but she is
extremely unpopular and everyone knows
it more popular than J but unpopular and
Joe Biden uh there are other people
Gavin Newsome is person someone people
talk about a lot um but it could end up
being Dean Phillips who finished second
and has this rather sort of appealing
backstory which I describ in the
magazine this week yeah so I me I mean I
guess there must be lots of Democrats
who are kind of looking on with horror
at the idea that they might end up with
a Biden Trump race again and not and and
pretty worried about their own candidate
by by that that his support suggests I
guess well it's not just Democrats I you
look Independence as well and and quite
a few Republicans if if you look at the
uh polls uh 60% of Americans say they
don't want or unenthusiastic about a
trump Biden rematch and yet this is what
they're getting uh and this speaks to
this dysfunction that seems to be
happening in American democracy where
they can't seem to select candidates uh
that um that have you know anything like
majority appeal BR thank you very much
Freddy next the co inquiry is now in
Edinburgh and has revealed the shocking
ways were made north of the Border but
as the snp's conduct reveal something
more about Devolution in Scotland
joining me to discuss is Fraser Nelson
and communities editor the national
Shona
Craven Fraser and Shona thank you for
joining us on spectator TV um Fraser you
write the lead story in the in the
magazine this week about the ongoing
covid inquiry in Scotland and there been
a few interesting Revelations this week
so can you start us off by telling us a
bit about them well it was never
apparent that the UK Co inquiry would
ever go to Scotland I mean we did have
Nicholas serson setting up her own
inquiry so I'm not quite sure she
expected the kind of forensic Force
which is now being Unleashed in
Edinburgh so it there for three weeks
and we're seeing a rather different Co
inquiry to the one we used to down here
in London we've had you know this pretty
bad QC um Hugo Keith and he has been s
liking the own sound of his voice not
really getting anything interesting uh
but now there's new guy jimie Dawson the
Scott he's a casc who's really revealing
um not just what happened during the co
during in Scotland but how the Scottish
executive sort of Scottish government
works day-to-day basis now the S&P had
various scandals over the years the
ferry Scandal the Alex salmon Scandal
and now the ongoing police investigation
into potential fraud and Corruption but
this was relatively new what we didn't
realize there was just the extent to
which a civil service has been coopted
as part of this so we saw already the
culture of secrecy of deleted messages
of being rather difficult to find out
what was really going on but we didn't
really know that the Scottish Civil
Service were playing the same game so
perhaps the most memorable moments came
when Ken Thompson one of the most senior
a civil zmans in Scotland we was found
to have exchanged various emails telling
his colleagues how to avoid foi be
careful of what you're saying is might
be discoverable in Freedom of
Information let's see if you can press
the clear chat and he he came up with a
phrase perhaps the most memorable phrase
plausible deniability are my middle
names now it's pretty bad to hear a
special advisor Junior Guy saying that
let alone the person who's supposed to
be assuring standards and probity now
down here you see the Civil servers
kicking off all the time against the
government you know things have got bad
when the ministers have to give a
ministerial Direction in other words
they they have to absolutely override
the Civil Service and they have to send
something write something saying that in
Scotland this hardly ever happens as an
indication according to the Institute of
government of just how much more
compliant really the machine is the
checks and balances that we have in
Westminster perhaps to a fault don't
seem to be happening up in Scotland and
I think the co inquiry has shown us the
extent of that Shona I mean you've been
following the Scottish inquiry this week
um when you take things like the
deletion of WhatsApp messages by
officials I mean it does sort of give
the impression doesn't it of a sort of
Cronin between I mean ministers and
officials do you do you agree with that
I think there's a level of informality
to these conversations definitely and I
think um some of the messages that have
come out obvious ly will have um
troubled people and and a lot of the
time just because they maybe seem quite
flippant and seem to be kind of joking
laughing emojis zipped mouth emojis and
things like that but I suppose some
people might think if there were some
Grand conspiracy or or real wrongdoing
to cover up then possibly the messages
wouldn't have had that tone and I think
if people are working together in very
difficult circumstances and over a long
period and using an informal channel to
communicate then there could be a degree
of informality of indiscretion of saying
things that you don't want them to be
fiable not because it would cause you
know a huge political Scandal but
because you're maybe speaking a little
bit more uh informally or perhaps
slagging someone off or making a
judgment about someone that ultimately
may be of very little relevance to the
co inquiry itself and in terms of actual
lessons learned about how decisions were
made but of course the problem of the
deletion the systematic deletion in line
with a policy um of course that's being
used as the reason for it but the
question then is why was that policy
introduced at that point and is it
compatible with the Integrity of an
inquiry um but I think that the deletion
obviously has dominated the headlines
and hopefully we will get some more
information on what emails if any were
written to capture any discussions that
were happening via WhatsApp are there
gaps in decision making where it's not
apparent where we went from A to B it
could have been a face-to-face
conversation that we don't know about
you know ultimately we're never going to
know all the conversations that took
place what's important is trying to
establish a trail of why this happened
why that happened and obviously with
regard to some of the more contentious
decisions about care homes in particular
about schools we've seen headlines today
about um evidence potentially being
ignored well there's bound to be
examples of somebody saying something
and it being ignored because there were
a lot of different stances on a lot of
um decisions that were made because it
was a a really difficult Balancing Act
for politicians I think it will be in
the coming weeks that we really get into
more important detail and identify if
there are gaps that these whatsapps
could potentially have provided
illumination for but it could be that
these whatsapps are of little relevance
it's just unfortunate people are always
going to wonder now because of this
systematic deletion yeah I I mean sha do
you think as well maybe that the S&P
have made a rod for their own backs here
in the sense of that they they make a
lot of hay about how the fact that
they're not the same as Westminster and
they pay a sort of emphasis on prob and
the like and now they're not sort of
meeting their own standard there yeah I
think definitely people have gone back
and said well hang on when when it was
Boris Johnson or Rishi sunak or whoever
doing this you said this um and I think
some people are a bit cynical about some
of the use of language you know saying
messages were not retained rather than
saying I deleted them you know that sort
of passive voice versus an active
decision so yes definitely when that was
going on and when those comments are
being made clearly the people making
those comments must have known
their position but felt confident in it
because I suppose of this policy and say
well we were just following a policy we
were keeping things secure um because
you know if the devices are falling into
the wrong hands or or whatever else but
it does create a bit of a problem we
also have the usual situation with
things at Westminster being quite so
appalling that you then have this
defensiveness from Scottish politicians
sometimes to say well our leader wasn't
compared to an out-of-control shopping
trolley and we weren't spiraling from
one thing to the next but of course that
should shouldn't be the bar the bar
should be much higher than being
significantly better than Boris Johnson
um and so I think we will see
defensiveness of we weren't as bad as
them but the Scottish public will be
looking for them to be an awful lot
better than that and fr it does seem
there's been some disingenuousness um
when it comes to the role of the
independence campaign and how that was
dealt with when it came to the pandemic
can you tell us a little bit about that
because it seems like there's something
come out that that suggests that the
Independence was definitely considered
whilst
the pandemic was going on yeah well
Nicholas sturon was challenged about
this during the pandemic she was saying
look are you guys talking about
independence because at the time the
opinion polls that hadn't really moved
after brexit not in the way that you'd
think all of a sudden started to show
yes to be ahead now we now know thanks
to the inquiry that the Scottish cabinet
did discuss independence and and they
did sort agree that they have a campaign
that could be based on SC surgeon's
response to covid the funny thing is
that she went hot fooot from that
cabinet meeting to a press conference
where she was asked directly about it
and this is what she said we're not
dealing with politics at the moment um
with this virus we're dealing with a
virus a virus that we know poses a real
risk to health and to life frankly
anybody who is trotting out political or
constitutional arguments is in the wrong
place completely and has found
themselves completely lost this is just
what we need to do from a public health
practical perspective to stop a virus
spreading so this of course makes people
think well hang on a minute not only
will you discussing Independence but you
are flatly and angrly denying that you
were in the first place and this comes
to a bigger concern that the the pursuit
of Independence has become the primary
objective of the Scottish government and
that the Civil Service should be and
pushing against that haven't been doing
so in the way that you would like so to
me this is a wider story about simply
the the concentration of power and we
saw during the Alex Ammon Scandal how
Hollywood doesn't have enough power
really to take on and to get to the
truth of these matters and there was um
I think Jason leech who was the national
Clinical Director there's a exchange
where I think he's talking to Kate
Forbes then Finance Minister and she's
saying look what's going on I need to be
told information is power and he REM
messaged her back saying look um I have
to say that that the first Minister and
Liz Lloyd or chief of staff are
basically deciding this themselves that
concentration of power isn't good for
any country you need by the way it
happened in London I mean you know it
was we saw that that the cabinet were
kept in the dark as well but when that
happens when it happens a systemic level
like Scotland it raises questions of
whether the Devolution settlement was
fundamentally misconstrued where the
Scottish Parliament lacks teeth to get
properly stuck into the government and
to challenge it so that's why I think
there's a bigger picture here that
whoever wins the next general election
might have to look at Scotland and ask
well really is 25 years on is a
Devolution settlement doing what we want
are Scots being short Changed by the
fact that whoever has got power whether
it was Scottish labor they were acting
as a cabal first of all then the S&P are
acting as a cabal you shouldn't be able
to act as a cabal in this small country
they should be I remember as a reporter
in the Scottish Parliament at the time
we genuinely believed we'd set up
something as as Scots that was going to
be better more transparency more honesty
more openness and now we find it's got
all the defects of Westminster a few
more thrown in beside sha do do you
agree with that and when it comes to the
flaws of devolution and and the S SMP in
particular well there there's a there's
an awful lot in there I mean I think you
know sort some of these Buzz phrases you
know cabal one party State you know
conjure up a certain impression I think
if we go back to the notion of Nicholas
sturgeon making these decisions herself
um I suppose you you maybe have to
consider what the general public would
think of that and how they were feeling
about that at the time she certainly was
the the face of the response in Scotland
of course she was on television every
day people appreciated the fact that she
seemed to be in charge that she seemed
to be making the decisions now obviously
those should be informed they should be
evidence-based and we will hear more
about whether that was felt to be the
case but also the notion of uh
Independence being a priority at that
time well I mean the be the biggest and
best argument for Independence for an
SNP government is to govern well and so
again would people think that Nicholas
sturgeon and the rest of her party
thinking if we do really well at
managing this pandemic that will help us
with the cause of Independence is that
dastardly Behavior or is that actually
just two goals that are aligned nobody
in Scotland wanted Scotland's response
to the pandemic to be fumbled um you
know even if you were the the most
committed unionist and wanted to see the
SNP fail in the long run you certainly
didn't want to see the Scottish
government H mess this up in the short
and when so much was at stake so I think
that it's a bit of a reach to suggest
that this was a big problem okay so the
example of Nicholas D saying that wasn't
something that was being discussed well
I mean In fairness what would have been
helped by her coming out and saying yes
to be honest you know never mind the
immediate pandemic we're thinking about
strategy for the future um I think I
don't know I maybe can't get too
exercise if if that was a white lie at
that particular point I do think that
those two goals were very much in
alignment and I think most people in
Scotland believe that Nicholas sturgeon
was the buck stopped with her and she
was making these decisions of course
when we get into the nitty-gritty of who
was doing what who who knew what who
understood what then we may identify
more flaws but I definitely don't agree
that Hollywood has all the problems that
Westminster has and more I think anyone
who takes the the most cursory look at
how Westminster politics operates will
be a gas that this sort of ridiculous
system is still in operation in a
supposedly sort of grownup Democratic
country yes of course you don't want
this uh iron Rod of discipline and
people not being able to desent and come
up with better policy but I don't think
um the chaos of Westminster is something
we should look at and try to emulate
further but the problem if there's not
enough debate you end up with really bad
ideas being churned out as we've seen
take gender M self ID that idea
collapsed take the named Guardian system
that Adar collapsed in the courts and
then you had ader to abolish juries now
what you're seeing here is that when
governments come up with bad ideas that
are ropey that would fall to Legal
challenge were supposed to be torn apart
by the parliament but that isn't
happening in Hollywood therefore they're
falling apart after they leave
Parliament so that's the scrutiny and
again um it's not this is this isn't
simply about Nicholas sergeon thinking
her deaf handling of the pandemic was
going to be an addition for Independence
this was about the question of whether
she was taking deliberately different
strategies to that of England to pursue
difference for its own sake during the
inquiry for example we heard from
another edber Professor one of Co
advisers saying that the politicians he
was around in Scotland were very
insistent for example that Scotland kept
lockdown for longer than England that
the the differentiation with England was
very important but it was never
explained to him what the public health
benefits for that would be in other
words they were looking for difference
for difference sake we also saw during
the inquiry how she um was flirting with
the idea of zero covid and her adviser
Debbie stretar was basically advocating
this as well in other words this having
a policy in Scotland very very different
to the one in England and the fact
Scotland would be similar to that of New
Zealand and Australia so what we're
seeing here is whether decisions are
being made not really because they
benefit the people of Scotland but
because they give a dividing line with
England for dividing land with the UK
and whether this consideration has
supplanted that of good government in
Scotland which might explain why the
education systems in such a mess which
might explain why police Scotland this
merged massive police force is so
dysfunctional and it might explain why
Devolution has not done what people like
me thought it would do when we supported
it 25 years ago I just think it's I
think it's questionable to suggest that
these uh differences for differences
sake were not supported by any evidence
however flawed that might have turned
out to be I mean the idea that Nicholas
sturgeon thought we'll do things
differently to show that we are a
different country and if it goes badly
if it backfires then we can say well it
was our own decision that we made you
know the public aren't going to be
impressed by that the fence sitters the
don't knows on Independence aren't going
to know Well you aren't going to say oh
well you know what it worked out badly
and thousands of people died but at
least we went our own way I'm really
inspired that we have Independence and
and have all our powers I just don't see
how strategically I mean Nicholas sturon
you know as a strategist has been pretty
effective and certainly only really
after resignation have a lot of the the
the bigger criticisms really come to the
for but I just don't think she would
risk making a decision for the
decision's sake if she didn't think it
was going to have a good outcome for
Scotland because that just doesn't make
any logical sense and some of the things
she was pushing obviously she hoped to
influence uh what would happen across
the UK there was this idea that there
could be these cross-nation meetings
where you know it would be a respectful
situation where it wouldn't just be
Boris Johnson dictating to everyone
we're going to do this like it or lump
it and so I think it's it's credible to
push for different uh approaches to
things like UK borders and to advocate
for that um while acknowledging that
clearly because of the the geography as
well as what's devolved and what's
reserved it Nicholas sergeon wasn't
going to get her way on all of these
things do you think it's been a bit of a
disappointment compared to what a lot of
us back Devolution thought it could be I
mean let's set Co aside but look at the
education system the way we're plunging
down the league tables like that you it
was this was never supposed to be the
plan and and I can't work out why in
general 25 years on Scots haven't been
able to produce better ideas it's
difficult to point anywhere we were
really better than England than than we
used to be well I suppose it depends if
you ask the person in the street do you
think that your life is better do you
think that things are better under
Devolution I'm not sure they would have
the same concerns that political
journalists would point to I think in
terms of Education obviously we have had
the massive disruption of Co and with
the Health Service obviously people also
point to before Co and say well hang on
you know things weren't going in the
right direction before as well but at
the end of the day should we be able to
make our own decisions about these
things or not I would agree with you
with a lot of the policies that I don't
think were uh a good idea or well
conceived a lot of these with
cross-party support we always have to
remember and I agree that there are huge
shortcomings in the scrutiny processes
we don't have a second chamber you know
as much as the House of Lords gets a lot
of stick um it does provide a scrutiny
function that we don't have at Hollywood
so I certainly think there's questions
to be asked about um a second chamber
and I certainly think there's a lot of
room for improvement but when you look
at what's going on at Westminster
particularly with education some of the
ideas about education in England which I
just don't think fit with the Scottish
mentality sometimes I read well I think
a lot of the stories you hear from
England about about Academy
about the sort of rigid enforcement of
rules and discipline and uniform codes
and things like that to me it does feel
like you're reading about quite a
different country now obviously you're
look you look at attainment gaps you
look at um inequalities in education and
that's extremely important but I think
culturally there is a difference there
and I don't think a lot of Scottish
people look enviously at what's going on
at Westminster and who the the UK
education secretary is and think oh that
person knows what they're doing whether
they think that the Scottish education
secretary is the best person is another
question but I just don't think many
people at this point or in the recent
past think oh if only Westminster was in
charge of this things would be better
right but isn't the whole point about
schools it's the parents who are in
charge if you don't like Katherine
burbling school you don't have to send
your kids there I mean to put it mly
that's not like every school you're
right she's got a very strict uniform
policy no talking in lunch time but
nonetheless she's got she's improved
results for her kids faster than any
other school in England or Scotland now
what can't work out is why Scots
Devolution was supposed to mean power
from the government to the people now to
me it seems that that power has been
hoarded in Hollywood it hasn't been
passed down to the parents and that's
why the academy program for example all
that means is parents get a greater
choice of who they want to go to um or
what sort of schools they want the kids
to that choice is not given to Scottish
parents and they can't work out why
Scottish parents shouldn't be trusted to
make these kinds of decisions because
they they'll make different decisions
you bet horses for courses different
families but I don't i' I've always seen
this as the Paradox of devolution that
your average Scott has less power less
control over their school less control
over the hospital Health Service because
ironically of devolution well maybe
that's just a a complete difference in
Outlook about whether we are citizens or
whether we are consumers of services and
I think with health services in
particular do people want to have lots
of choices have that power actually when
you're unwell do you want power or do
you just want to know that where you go
will look after you rather than being
given that choice I mean a lot of
parents with respect with respect with
schools parents do make choices they
make choices of where to live they make
choices about placing requests make
choices about private school but a lot
of parents I think want their children
want to know that wherever their
children go to school they will get a
good education they will be socializing
with children from all different
backgrounds and they want to feel that
they are part of a a joint effort in
Scotland for for everyone to be well
educated not just thinking well how can
I get a leg up for my particular child
and I think that's a difference between
being a citizen and being a consumer of
services where you know some people end
up winners and some people are losers
and some people have to go to a school
that's not as good I don't think most
Scottish people want to see anyone go to
a quote unquote bad school or have a bad
health care experience we want everyone
to have equal opportunities if I will
accept the Westminster has got bit too
much challenge a bit too much chatis a
bit bit little too much resignations
would you accept that there isn't enough
of that in Hollywood that there is
simply not enough debate there's not
enough testing I mean here it's you
there barely a day passes about somebody
calling for the prime minister to resign
I get that that's too much but the fact
that Ash Reagan was the first minister
to resign in Scotland for 14 years the
fact that there is the Hollywood
committee really doesn't have the teeth
to challenge the government don't you
think there could be a little bit more
Scot on Scot you know action in
Hollywood to because governments need
opposition they need scrutiny they need
an independent civil service and they
need people resigning now and again yeah
well maybe watch this space I mean I
think a lot of people think there is
quite a lot of internal disagreement
within the SNP quite a lot of rebellions
let's see how the budget goes for
example I think the leadership contest
surprised a lot of people with just how
diverse the party actually is and I
think a lot of people are perhaps
keeping their powder dry waiting to see
how this general election campaign goes
I don't think hza yusf is particularly
envied as the leader so I think there
could be um a lot of room for
disagreement whether that means
resignations or whether the people who
are in the posts are are loyalists to
Hamza YF H to to the end um I think
we'll need to wait and see but I think
um in recent times you can't say that
there hasn't been some pretty healthy
and robust debate within the party thank
you very much sha thank you
Fraser next for the magazine this week
NHS psychiatrist Max pton has written
about the rise of ketamine misuse in
Britain and the lack of awareness
surrounding this party drug Max joins me
now to
discuss Max thank you for joining us on
spectator TV um you're W in the magazine
this week about the dangers of the drug
ketamin um for any viewers who aren't
familiar with with ketamin um can you
give us bit brief explanation about what
it is and and why people are taking it
yeah sure I mean actually it's
interesting because it's it's a
relatively new drug I think for people
to be using it's now very very
widespread it's one of the most common
drugs that people under the age of 24
are using um and actually when I was at
University 25 years ago i' never even
heard of ketamin um so sort of roughly
speak or kind of s medically speaking
it's a it's what we call a dissociative
anesthetic itic and it is it is used in
medicine it's used in anesthesia um it
helps patients with kind of things like
pain management um and to get people off
into into uh when they're being enzed um
and it's also been more experimentally
used more recently very very recently
probably the last couple of years um in
the treatment of depression um but it's
it's it's CL classed as a as a form of
anesthetic basically and it was
developed back in the 1960s early 60s um
but it was used um in combat situations
in the Vietnam War um and that was when
it kind of it was sort of really
widespread used within medicine within
the Vietnam War and then following on
from that it was used more within the
anesthetic area and and really since the
80s it's been a drug of misuse we might
say um but really kind of 80s and 90s it
was used um really by just only hardcore
clubbers so it was with that kind of
like really underground um sort of scene
um so sort of you know along with things
like ecstasy back in the ' 80s and '90s
and then it seem to have a a bit of a
long period um during the na naughties
and then really the last kind of like 10
15 years we've really seen it kind of
taking off and certainly I think in the
last kind of five six seven years it
seems It's really really really
escalated and it seems Max that it's
particularly dangerous I mean you
mentioned in your piece I think the
times said last year something like 41
students who died had it in their
systems I mean what what makes it
dangerous
particular I mean that's a really good
question I think first what's
interesting is people's attitudes
towards it it seems to have missed you
know kind of if you think of heroin you
think of the 1980s and HIV and hepatitis
if you think of ecstasy you might think
of people like liabetes um you know
there kind of lots of big headlines
around things like cocaine and things
like that actually ketam has kind of
flown below the radar quite a lot um and
I think one of the one of his biggest PR
coups um you know if it had a PR Company
it' be winning Awards is they actually
it's manag to um it it it's still a
Class B drug so actually While most of
other drugs that we call hardcore drugs
are class A this is still Class B and
actually that has kind of come with it
there's an attitude that kind of it's
not that really that bad it's Class B
it's not kind of really serious um and
so so we sort of so when I speak to
patients A lot of it is around their
attitudes of like well i' never do
proper hardcore drugs I just smoke weed
and I do ketamin but actually we know
ketamin is a hugely hugely Dangerous
Drug so basic people take it for this
sense of euphoria they get the problem
comes that actually that is only a very
specific low
dose it is an anesthetic it's a
tranquilizer it's often called called A
Horse tranquilizer because it's
sometimes used in vety medicine and in
fact one of the one of the slang names
is donkey dust U because it's used for
like to knock out large animals
obviously if it's knocking out large
animals it's all it's all can also can
knock out you you know 18 19 20 year old
so the the problem is that actually
dosing is incredibly difficult for a
number of reasons it's hard to know
exactly what you've taken people are
often taking with other things as well
so they lose track of what they when
they last took it and also it's often of
very frequently cut with other things so
not only do you not know what you're
getting but also the dose that you're
taking you don't know how strong the
actual the power that you're taking is
um so in in a higher does um it then
creates this kind of dissociative state
where people lose a track of of of time
they start um they start kind of
retreating into themselves they're
unable to communicate with the outside
world it's often a very very scary
experience it's what they call a khole
so people fall into a khole they are
often they they appear paralyzed they're
not they're they're awake but they are
no interaction with the outside world
you can't speak to them they can't
communicate and actually then that then
moves on to them respirat depression um
it increases your heart rate and so on
um and then it leads to death and in
fact Matthew Perry the uh the friends
actor actually the autopsy report said
that he died from from the acute effects
of of ketamin and actually this guy was
a seasoned drug user you know he he he
was very used to using drugs and the
concern is that actually even people
that seem to know what or think they
know what they're doing because of the
way that ketamine affects you because of
the fact around the dosing it's actually
almost impossible to to to take a safe
illicit dose I see so there's the danger
there and then you you mentioned as on
the piece that there's sort of long-term
effects um for for high high dosage
users which which sort of concern their
bladder can you tell us a bit about that
too yeah well actually interesting it's
not even necessarily high dose users so
there is a thing and actually I've seen
this a couple of times in
A&E um and uh and I mean every urologist
you speak to will have seen this now and
this is new this is a relatively new
thing if you go back 15 years as I say
it was quite an unusual thing to see now
particularly working in the city if
we'll see it all the time so it causes a
number of problems specifically to the
bladder so of course there's all of the
problems that any drugs can cause around
you know sort generally if you take too
much but actually ketamine directly
affects specifically the
bladder and it does a number of things
to it it can cause like an ulcerative
kind of condition so it ulcerates and it
is can be absolutely agonizing so you
have these open wounds inside the
bladder so I mean I'm not going to go
into tooo much detail but it's
incredibly painful and very very
unpleasant and actually the tragedy is
people often end up taking more ketamin
because they for getet it's an
anesthetic they end up taking more
ketamin to try and get over the pain and
actually that just makes the situation
worse and worse it also causes a
retraction of your bladder and it can be
really quite serious it can be to the
size of a toddler so it can be massively
massively SW of bladder which means
people have frequently H to go to the
toilet and actually in some cases we've
they've seen they've had to remove the
bladder entirely and and and give a a
false bladder um um so I mean it can be
cred and actually the the sort of
initially it was felt well this is a
quite an idiosyncratic unique reaction
to KET it's unusual reaction um probably
you know it's probably quite rare and
actually Studies have now been shown
that probably about affects about 20% of
users and actually some Studies have
shown it it's actually up to 90% of
users depending on on uh on which which
kind of particular studies you're
looking at um when I sort of talk to Pat
and even friends about this cuz I've got
even friends that are using it um and I
kind of said guys do you not know about
the risks you know it's an anesthetic
you could fall into a khole you could
die you could choke on your tongue lift
all these things and I talk about
bladder problems people are just they I
mean I had somebody a couple of months
ago didn't believe me and had to Google
it I was like I've been a doctor for 20
years I definitely know what I'm talking
about it's just really surprising how
again in some are with with some illicit
substances there seems to be so much
knowledge even alcohol you say to stop
anyone on the street you say you to ask
about alcohol they say oh it damages
your liver you ask about ketamin users
don't seem to know what it's what what
the potential that how it can affect
them Max later on in the show we're
talking to Professor David nut who's
talked obviously a lot in the past about
legalization and I'm guessing his
argument will be that if we legalize it
you'll allow people to control the
dosage they have they'll to be informed
and educated they won't make you know
mix ketamine with alcohol um I mean what
do you that do you think there is a a
safe way of of taking this um do you see
any Merit in that yeah that's very good
I mean I'm I'm a great fan of actually
profess not I think he's great I mean I
would say he's he is an academic um now
you know he doesn't as far as I know he
doesn't see patience so much and
certainly doesn't work in drug clinics
but I mean he's incredibly knowledgeable
about the pharmacological side of things
um I would say just to kind of preface
everything is that actually ketamin has
been shown to be really interesting in
the treatment of depression in certain
time types of
depression um um for people with
treatment resistant depression it seems
to really potentially have been a very
Innovative interesting area and I know
that Professor nut's very interested in
that is's doing research into it and and
I and I was so I wouldn't want to scare
people for ketamin it's very different
being given a ketamine infusion in a
hospital to snorting it off a key in a
toilet in a club um and that's kind a
really important distinction to make the
question around legisl
legalization I'm very wary of
decriminalization cuz I think actually
all we do is we allow allow the drug
dealers basically then take over and we
just turn a blind eye it doesn't help us
or protect anybody um and it just allows
criminality to run rif I have I've
thought a lot about about legalization
when I first started as a doctor I was
quite against it and I thought actually
no people need protecting they they're
not making really informed decisions um
because they haven't seen the kind of
things that you know that really is
going to happen to them um and and
actually we need to try kind of treat
those people still with kindness and
compassion because often they're using
illicit substances because of deep
emotional problems but actually we need
to make sure that we're protecting them
from it I have to say I feel now having
worked in drug services for many years
and with lots and lots of drug users and
worked in a and seen the Fallout of drug
use over years I've kind shifted
actually I kind of feel that we had a
decision we had a choice we had two
things we had to decide either Legalize
It Or Don't Legalize It And criminalize
it and actually we didn't really decide
either we didn't go down the kind of
Singapore model where actually it's
incredibly punitive we Crush down on
people we're very strict um and actually
we kind of had like a bit of a halfway
house um and I think there's an argument
of like well we're not going to win the
war on drugs because we never really
started it really when you compare to
other countries where they really really
cracked out now actually I don't want to
live in Saudi Arabia or Singapore to be
honest
um so I kind of feel that well actually
Professor n has got a really good point
actually if we did legalize it and we s
to people look there were these risks
and we taxed it and you could only get
it from select kind of you know
authorized places um that there was some
kind of you know prohibition or there
was some kind of um legislation in place
to make sure that people under a certain
age can get access to it and that there
was very strong um uh penalties for
people that did Supply it um to people
who are under and so on in a sort of
similar way but maybe much more stronger
than we do with alcohol and and even
cigarettes now um actually it would
enable us to kind of monitor its use it
would ensure that we could have it so
that it was in its purest form it would
take it out the hands of
criminals um so I've actually have
shifted much more I think there is an
argument for making some drugs still
ilicit illegal and they were made
illicit substances but I certainly think
the problem is at the moment we have we
we've got alcohol which is a depressant
we don't really have if you want to go
out and party and you want an enhanced
experience if you use alcohol
essentially your night's going to end
probably quite early if you want to be
out until 6:00 in the morning I think
they're very far from a very well-known
nightclub and people are coming out
literally at 6:00 7 8 in the morning
there is no way that everyone coming out
there has been drinking alcohol all
night they're all on drugs um and if we
kind of acknowledge for whatever reason
there's people that want to do that we
need we need some kind of stimulant that
is that's legal so be it ecstasy or
ketamin or cocaine or something we need
to kind of understand that there's
people are using substances for specific
reasons and actually we're not our
legislation at the moment doesn't allow
for a whole cohort of people doesn't
allow them to use anything legally um
and so they they're deciding I
personally think it's an error but they
are deciding to do to to to get stuff
illegally um so I I actually think he
has a very persuasive argument as I say
I I feel that there was a decision was
made at some point
and we decided not to have a war on
drugs and it's pointless considering
that we killing ourselves that we did
thank you Max for joining us on
spectator
TV before we move on to our final
segment we also caught up with Professor
David nut an author and renowned
supporter of drug liberalization David
thank you for joining us on spectator TV
um here to talk to us about ketamine
today uh you've written a lot in the P
of you've spoken a lot in the past about
sort of the benefits of drug
legalization and things that could come
from that for people who are maybe less
familiar with your arguments um could
you sort of briefly make that case here
well in essence uh I believe people are
rational and if they actually know what
they're doing they're likely to come to
less harm than if they do things which
they think are safe uh with drugs of
unclear Providence certainly of unclear
strength and dose in which case they can
often come to harm so I think a a policy
where you have a regulated market or at
the very least uh decriminalization of
users so and testing so people can find
out what they're doing without fear of
prosecution that is the most rational
Way Forward and um it's been proven
because dut have been doing that for the
last 30 years and they have very very
very few deaths from drugs whereas we
have lots of deaths and drugs and am I
right in saying you believe sort of
legalization should be applied to katam
katamine as well
when we say legalization what I mean is
that that what we should be doing is at
the very at the very least
decriminalizing possession I think we
should also encourage people to be able
to access
testing very very readily so they know
what they're taking but I haven't done
enough of an
analysis of the realities of a kmy
market uh that's something that we've
done before with um our alcohol and and
tobacco and opiates I suspect if we did
that analysis it would also come to the
same conclusion that a some kind of
regulated market where people knew what
they were getting where those people who
were buying it could be vetted might
even have to have evidence from their
doctor that they were mentally well
enough to have it where they could be
given safety advice uh and um also been
told what to do if things go wrong I
think that kind of approach which could
well work I think it it's certainly
likely to be better than what we have at
present Max makes the case in his piece
that that ketamine in particular is
quite dangerous in the sense that when
it's mixed with alcohol it's very
difficult for your body to regulate and
that's the kind of the danger point
which is that it might be safe maybe
some or most of the time but it can be
particularly lethal um if you get if you
make that judgment wrong in terms of
quantities I mean do you do you buy that
I mean because that seems like something
that that's sort of testing and um
legalization maybe wouldn't be able to
deal with no you AB he's he's right for
particularly for naive users it's a huge
issue I mean I just want to say a couple
of things about that there is no doubt
that ketamine is much more dangerous if
it's used with other drugs particularly
if it's used with alcohol because
they're both
sedatives and they both they work in
interestingly they're sort of a double
whammy on the brain and together they
can produce a state of great
intoxication and
anesthesia and sometimes that kills you
and sometimes you just do other strange
things like decide you can swim in a
Bath Underwater and then you can't so
that seemed to be what Perry did so yes
ketamine used particularly with other
sedatives is very dangerous but my
argument would be um is it more
dangerous than alcohol probably not uh
there's we know that very few people die
of ketamine who aren't using other drug
so I think if you had it in a situation
where there was appropriate
education and uh people knew it as I say
the doses they were taking and were
warned not to use it inappropriately you
might well get away or at least reduce
the number of these deaths like that's
the recent student death um where she
was clearly drunk in fact I have a
general message to anyone uh don't ever
drug and drink and and you know if
you're drunk don't take other drugs
because you don't know what's in them I
mean it might be ketamine it might not
be it might be fenil or some other even
more dangerous substance so alcohol is a
problem because it encourages people to
take risks and it makes them more
vulnerable to the effects of the risks
they're taking with other drugs um David
you've talked as well in the past about
the sort of maybe there are some
beneficial uses of ketamine particular
with regards to mental health and that
and depression could you tell us a bit
about
that well yeah I mean ketamine is a
really valuable medicine it's one of the
most important medicines in the world
half of all the
surgery done in subsaharan Africa is
done on ketamine why because you don't
need doctors to give ketamine it doesn't
cause respiratory depression you don't
need to ventilate people you don't need
anatis basically a trained nurse can do
ketamine adequately to provide for
surgery so it's a hugely important
medicine and I just want to emphasize
this because the hysteria particularly
generated a few years ago in China about
the misuse of
ketamine led the Chinese government to
petition the United Nations to ban
ketamine globally to try to stop the
misuse in in Hong Kong essentially and
we and and also doctors and and and and
vets protested this ter you know that
would be an utterly utterly ridiculous
approach so Banning ketamine in order to
reduce the harms for recreation use will
be absolutely outrageous totally
disproportionate so I just want to
emphasize that banning has potentially
very perverse consequences and just as
an aside when ketamine was rescheduled
it was once upon a time it was um Class
C and then it was rescheduled to class B
in an attempt to reduce harms which it
didn't it had a huge negative impact
because it used to be being held by
paramedics and and people at festivals
to deal with broken legs Etc and then
they couldn't do that because they had
to have a special license to hold
ketamine there so there was a year when
it it was very very hard for people to
do emergency repairs to people in in the
field so so banging up the
classification penalties usually just
has no impact on use and that's get in
the way of clinical value so the
clinical value I've already mentioned is
if through anesthesia worldwide it's
also for the last 20 years being
developed in lowd dose infusions for
pain syndromes so pain entists and other
doctors use it and in the last 10 years
it's undergone a fascinating
Resurrection as an
anti-depressant because it seems to
allow people one or two doses of
ketamine break down patterns of negative
thinking and allow people to escape from
really deep treatment resistant
depression so it's turning out to be an
enormously valuable drug in Psychiatry
as well I see um max makes the the
argument in his peace David um I imagine
you disagree with this that the sort of
studies that show ketamine is beneficial
for your mental health for example
almost act as a bit of a PR for the drug
and make it seem more safe to
recreational users um do you think
there's anything to that or do you think
it maybe needs to be made clearer that
you're not doing a controlled study
you're taking you know a ton of ketamine
at the weekend and it's it's different
sort of uh
proposition yeah I mean the reality is I
don't think the use of ketamine is
changed since it became a medicine I I
don't think it's a PR I think the
reality is there are a lot of patients
and you can talk to people like Rupert
mcshain in Oxford who's been running a
ketamine CL for 10 years and saving
lives no I I don't think it's a PR at
all but but even if it was encouraging
people to use which I I I say I don't I
suspect it isn't the way around that is
education it's not Banning it it's not I
mean this is great these calls make it
Class A
well I should put my hand up I was
actually chairing the committee that
made it a control drug in the first
place be before
2004 it wasn't controlled we looked
spent about two years on the acmd
evaluating the hars of cine and we
decided you know ra rather grudgingly we
ought to try to give a message of harm
by rep putting it into the misus of
drugs act as a Class C drug I don't
think that had any impact on use
whatsoever and then a few more deaths
and then it was moved to class B and now
they moved to class A but the reality is
people who use the use
ketamine they don't actually care what
the class is because the users it has
almost no impact on and uh and the the
people who are selling it the difference
in penalties for a dealer between a
Class C drug and a Class A drug are
trivial because the government has
actually distorted the drug laws so that
basically you supposedly attract the
maximum pretty much the maximum penalty
14 years for class B and life for class
A well I mean very few people get 14
years with a l sentence so the reality
is the penalties
are
not a dissuasion to people who are
dealing it they have abs zero impact on
the users what users need is to know how
much they've taking and and what it is
and you know we've certainly seen
examples in the states there's a lot of
examples now of ketamine being cut with
feny which is considerably more
dangerous than ketamine alone so so
knowing what you're taking either
through testing or through having a
regulated market my is my view the best
way David you mentioned that for drug
dealers I mean do you think the
classific ation system makes any
difference for users who might be be
facing possession for example are they
more like to use ketamine because it's
below say cocaine or cannabis in the in
the
schedule no the reality is drug users
know more about drugs and politicians
and they know that the drug laws don't
make any sense brilliant thank you very
much
David finally in an Ever digital world
have parents become addicted to tracking
their children what could be the
implications of this Mary Wakefield WR
wrote about why she's changing her mind
about snooping on her child she joins me
now along with d'vorah heitner author of
the book growing up in public growing of
age in a digital
world Mary and d'vorah thank you for
joining us on spectator TV um Mary you
write in the magazine this week about
the sort of Rise of people tracking each
other on their phones but in particular
um tracking your children oh yes and you
mentioned that whilst you've done this
in the past you maybe now think it's a
mistake so can you can you tell us a bit
about about that and and why you think
that maybe is yes I mean I didn't really
think about it too much um until and and
I've signed up to find my friends so my
husband and some of my family do know
where I am and it's been kind of useful
but the other day I went out without my
phone and F this felt this sort of great
sense of euphoria and freedom and I
pinpointed it to not being able to be
tracked my husband can't just text and
say oh I see you're in the supermarket
can you pick up some apples and I just
realized the luxury and joy of no one
knowing where you are and that made me
think my God all the you know generation
that's on Snap maps and stuff um they
don't know that freedom and my own child
who I'm afraid I do track he won't know
that freedom of never being watched so
so that's what I was writing about
that's what I'm worried about and as you
say it's not it's not just you it's it's
a very common thing these days do you
find well gentics I don't know anything
you know um but you know as a parent of
a seven-year-old um I do find more and
more parents are beginning to track
their children and what wasn't normal a
few years ago people you know gave
trackers a funny look is now completely
routine you know well where do you put
your Apple tag oh I just stick it in
their collar and I've just realized
there's something you know there is a
there's a price to pay if if my mother
told me now oh darling yes we tracked
you throughout your childhood and you
never knew it I'd be horrified so should
I be doing the same thing to my
kid D'Or what do do you make of this
it's something you've written about a
lot I mean are you Pro or anti sort of
tracking
children I think for the most part anti
but certainly I think if we're going to
do it we should be overt and not covert
so they should know if they're being
tracked how they're being tracked and
when what's our plan for turning it off
you know when I talk to parents who are
tracking their kids at University and
they're not living at home and they're
saying oh are they leaving their housing
and going to class and they're watching
The Little Dot that seems very extreme
so working your way back to a
seven-year-old you know there may be
situations where they're riding their
bicycle to a new part of town where it
does feel like a good idea to see if
they got there and maybe in some ways we
can even say it's adding to their
freedom because we feel more comfortable
letting them take a new independent
experience because we can track but at a
certain point I think that euphoria that
you felt being untracked is worth
thinking about and kids need to know
that they have the autonomy and the
resilience to find their way out out of
a scrape find their way home and that
actually a set of skills including
knowing when and how to ask for help in
the immediate environment and who is the
safe person to ask for help if you need
help is actually more important because
even if you're tracking your kid what
are you going to do if suddenly their
phone turns off like what's your plan
you know I mean and how will you manage
the anxiety that that causes in you as
well um Dora you mentioned that so some
some parents taking this as far as their
children going to University I mean I
mean do you think that seems absolutely
incredible but do you think that's quite
a common thing in the United States it's
more common than you might think and and
I think in general parents in other
places run a little less anxious so
maybe in the UK parents are not doing
that as much and people don't tend to of
course go as far away for University so
maybe there's less anxiety uh I don't
know how often kids are learning to
drive or at what age but I do think
those are the inflection points that we
see here in the US parents are getting
very anxious and and
uh over half of the students in one
study at University said their parents
are tracking them some of the time so
that was that was eye opening for me
because the thing is if you get used to
having that data when do you turn it off
exactly so I mean I understand it with
the seven-year-olds apart from you told
me I have to be honest with my son but
if I said to him darling this device is
tracking you wherever you go if I was
him I couldn't help just but you know
throw it into a trash can or or put it
on the back of someone else's bike or
just you know I mean the potential for
sort of Mischief is huge um but yeah no
no most of um my teenage godchildren and
even the ones at University just
naturally assume their parents will know
where they are um and I do think there's
a price to pay for that not least in the
for for the parents because if you're
always looking and I would be always
looking you know you're never really
letting them go you're not really
letting them develop Independence even
if they don't know it if you're sitting
there on on find my friends watching
them and what do you get financially too
like if they're on an app where they're
spending money that's shared family
money like then you see where they spent
their money too if they have like apple
wallet or you know Google pay and you're
that's tied to you you know you might
not see them on the map but you know
where they just bought a hamburger or
whatever do you think keeps them keeps
the it does infantilize them a little
bit doesn't it if as a parent you're
always in that overseeing
role you're not letting them grow up
properly yeah and they may not learn how
to make their own plans independently or
again get elves out of a difficult
situation yeah it just is a a diff
different quality of feeling when you're
completely alone and unobserved you have
to rely on your own resources don't you
Mary since you've written this piece
there has been the sort of the push back
in the office by lots of people here who
are sort of tracking their friends and
have their parents there been some quite
vigorous feeling but it's completely
normal and fine and I'm insane to worry
about it the argument and I think that
the the the force of their emotion is
covering up the fact that they know
there's something wrong with it would
say and I actually just I find it very
weird and a bit creepy but they would
sort of make the case what's the harm in
it you know if it puts people at eased
knowing where I am then then and you
know I've got nothing to hide I go to my
work I go back home I go to you should
have something to hide I think if you
haven't got something to hide there's
something wrong with you have things to
hide what what's your view of the adult
side of it Deora do you think it's fine
when when adults track each other as
well I actually think that when we we
track our kids we're also teaching them
that it's normal to do in adult Rel
relationships and I think we have to
question that like if our kids are in a
romantic relationship with someone who
wants to track them all the time you
know is that normal or does that border
on abuse is that is that problematic
like why does someone need to know where
you are all the time or and then what's
the next level the next level is a lot
of parents might read their kids' texts
well what if your kid's romantic partner
wanted to read all their texts would you
think that was invasive and I I
recognize that the parenting
relationship is different than a
relationship between two equal Partners
at the same time if we normalize all of
this invasion of privacy at what point
do do kids learn that in any
relationship they might have some rights
to privacy that maybe someone shouldn't
be reading all their texts or tracking
their location 247 do you get the sense
there's a a big generational divide over
this still with sort of you mentioned
this in your peace Mary as well but sort
of the older Generations are still you
know find this find this incredibly
creepy as as we do or or is it sort of
taking over everywhere now it is
definitely something kids and adults are
getting more accustomed to I also talked
to a lot of people who are tracking
their elderly parents and I actually
think that the case of someone you know
with like Dementia or something who
might get lost is a little bit different
than tracking your teenager you know if
you're looking at someone who really is
in danger in public places or who might
get wander you know wander and be
confused again I think it's something to
do carefully I don't think we should
just start tracking our parents just
because we're curious you know how
they're spending their days but that
might be a situation where someone is a
risk to themselves where it might make
sense ethic so I mean I I think all of
these Technologies need to be used with
intention and and thought and not just I
think it might ease my anxiety to know
where my 15-year-old is at every second
of every day you know did you ever ditch
class when you were 15 and did you live
to tell the tale and learned a lot from
it really you know um yeah we don't have
to be comfortable all the time we don't
have to you know medicate our anxiety
all the time um yeah I mean I have sort
of friends in their 20s who've been been
stalked by their ex-boyfriends because
they haven't learned to let go you split
up with someone and then on Snap Maps
they're following them around the place
and and getting worked up at night about
the fact that this person might be
seeing someone else I think it's
horrific to to be able to see where all
your exes are in the world and who
they're with you know you mentioned as
well Mary that it might be a bit of a
false friend in the sense of it might
let you put let your guard down that you
think you can be rescued at a moment's
notice almost yeah I I I I wonder what
d'vorah thinks of that you know do you
get a full sense of security if you're
tracked yeah I do think that that it
doesn't if you don't think you have
responsibility for keeping track of
yourself or finding your way home if
you're lost or figuring out what to do
as I used to when I would go into New
York City as a as a teenager with my
friends from the suburbs and then you
know sort out what to do like oh I spent
all my money now how do I get home well
that's a good problem to figure it out
yeah exactly I'm not going to say it's
wonderful to ride back to the suburbs in
the toilet of the train but you know
it's a it's a very useful skill to have
developed voting trainers I'm not
advocating law breaking on your show
exactly but I am saying that you know
you want kids to have what I would
consider to be sort of mild problems to
solve where the end of the world isn't
you know nigh when they solve the
problem you know when I taught my kid to
ride the public bus you know if he
missed our stop he was just going to end
up at the mall right that's not a reason
to track him if he ends up at the mall
he'll turn around and get back and get
on the other bus it's not like oh no
he's going to you know end up getting
out of the country by mistake without a
passport right like nobody will let that
happen so I think it's really important
to look at the actual risks your kids
face whether it's walking or biking or
taking the train to school whether it's
deciding that you're not going to track
your kid to make sure they're on time
there's also a lot of grade tracking
going on and you can track a lot about
how your kids doing academically
and that might be too much information
to have you know you do need to see
every single quiz every single homework
grade yeah I suppose we have quite a
safest culture don't we at the moment
Mary and you know it might well be you
know it we used to let kids outplay much
further for example and that sort of
radius of how far we let let children go
narrowed and narrowed yeah I'm sure doru
agrees yeah do you yeah sorry go ahead I
was goingon to say do you think at some
point it will be seen as very
irresponsible if you have lost your
child and you haven't been tracking the
moment yeah I think it it it operates on
a ratchet system it's very hard to go
back which is why we've all got to be so
careful you know it's easy to put all
these tracking things on and think
safety first but it's very hard to say
I'll take them off again because then
you think oh my God if this is the one
time I don't use the Apple tag and it's
the time that something happens then
I'll feel so so much more comfortable so
proceed with caution yeah and do you
find dvor sort of difficult to say to
parents because they could equally say
could come back to you and say well you
know if something did happen to them and
that was that was the time I wasn't
tracking them and something bad happened
how could I justify that to myself I
mean what what do you say it's when own
thinking I think it's I I I do
understand that and I live with those
anxieties too and we live in a world
where the news media frankly you know
overplays some very unlikely dangers and
underplays the sort of day-to-day things
that our kids skills our kids really
need but I would say whether or not
you're tracking your kid they still need
to know how to ask a safe stranger they
still need basic self-defense skills
they still need to be aware of their
surroundings right and we do a lot to
teach our kids stranger danger but we
maybe don't do enough to teach them wait
how do you talk to The Friendly Stranger
you know if you have a kid who can't
talk to the children's librarian to ask
where a book is or to the crossing guard
or someone who is a safe adult to get
directions from and we also have to
remember we don't want to teach our kids
such a high level of threat assessment
that we feel like they need a phone or a
tracking device just to ride their bike
around the block
because we do live in a world where most
people would help a kid who fell off
their bike right we don't live in a
world where everybody is a terrible
person um and would harm your child and
so we don't want to teach our kids a a
disproportionate level of threat yeah
very good point actually what are you
telling your kid if you put a tracking
device in their school bag every day
you're telling them that the world is so
unsafe I need to watch you all the time
you know which just isn't
true brilliant thank you Mary thank you
d'vorah that's it for this week once
again if you enjoy spectator TV do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss an episode thanks again
for watching and do join us again next
[Music]
week